.
>> THE BODIES OF SIX CIVILIANS
OF GOTCHA WOUNDS WAS FOUND IN
THE BASEMENT OF A HOME OUTSIDE
THE CAPITAL CITY OF KYIV.
MORE EVIDENCE OF WAR CRIMES ON
ATROCITIES INCLUDING THE
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR GENERAL
WHO EARLIER SPOKE WITH CNN'S
FRED PLEITGEN.
AND WARNINGS OUR VIEWERS, THIS
REPORT CONTAINS GRAPHIC IMAGES.
>> EVEN AS RUSSIAN TROOPS IN
MASS IN EASTERN UKRAINE FOR
WHAT THE U.S. BELIEVES WILL BE
A HUGE DEFENSIVE, A THOROUGH
TEASING KYIV CONTINUE DIGGING
UP BODIES.
PAINSTAKING WORK THAT GOES HAND
IN HAND WITH INVESTIGATING
RUSSIA'S ATTACK ON KYIV AND
POSSIBLE CRIMES COMMITTED BY
VLADIMIR PUTIN'S INVADING
TROOPS.
>> PROSECUTOR GENERAL ARENA
VENEDIKTOVA IS LEADING THE
CHARGE.
SHE SPOKE TO ME AT THE EDGE OF
A MASS GRAVE IN THE KYIV SUBURB
OF BUCHA.
>> FOR US, THE BEST MOTIVATION
IS JUSTICE.
AND OF COURSE, WE UNDERSTAND
THAT ALL UKRAINIANS WANT
JUSTICE.
TRUE AND FAST JUSTICE.
THAT'S WHY WE DO EVERYTHING TO
DOCUMENT ALL THE EVIDENCE.
ALL THE FACTS OF WORK-AROUNDS
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN UKRAINE.
>> FRENCH FORENSIC
INVESTIGATORS ARE NOW ALSO ON
THE SCENE.
NOT BECAUSE UKRAINE LACKS
EXPERTISE, BUT BECAUSE KYIV
WANTS TO BE AS TRANSPARENT AS
POSSIBLE IN THE FACE OF RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION EFFORTS.
>> WE WANT TO DO OUR JOB
ABSOLUTELY OPEN.
WITH STANDARDS OF INTERNATIONAL
HUMANITARIAN LAW.
IT'S A VERY HIGH STANDARD.
THAT'S WHY, WHEN HERE, WE HAVE
OUR INTERNATIONAL COLLEAGUES,
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THEY CAN SEE
EVERYTHING.
THEY CAN SEE THE REAL SITUATION
HERE.
THE REAL GRAVES.
REAL DEAD BODIES.
>> AFTER UKRAINIAN FORCES
MANAGED TO EXPEL RUSSIAN TROOPS
FROM AROUND KYIV AND SOME OTHER
AREAS THEY OCCUPIED IN UKRAINE,
AUTHORITIES HAVE DISCOVERED
SCORES OF THAT BODIES.
TODAY, ANOTHER SIX FOUND IN
JUST ONE BASEMENT OUTSIDE KYIV.
THE PROSECUTOR TELLS ME THEY
ARE COLLECTING EVIDENCE AND
THOUSANDS OF CASES.
>> NOW WE ARE STARTING MORE
THAN 6000 CASES.
IT'S CASES OF WAR CRIMES, CASES
AGAINST HUMANITY, AND WE
STARTED ON THE FIRST DAY, WE
STARTED THEM CASE ABOUT
GENOCIDE.
>> ALL THIS AS RUSSIA STILL
CLAIMS ITS FORCES THAN INVADED
UKRAINE HAVE NOT HARMED AND
HE'S.
I SAID FROM THE BEGINNING AND
WANT TO DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO
THAT.
>> THERE ARE SOME OF THE U.S.
AT THE TOP LEVEL SPOKE ABOUT A
POSSIBLE WAR CRIMES TRIAL
AGAINST VLADIMIR PUTIN.
THAT'S SOMETHING YOU THINK
COULD EVER BE POSSIBLE,
SOMETHING YOU'RE WORKING
PROVIDE EVIDENCE FOR?
>> OF COURSE, I THINK THAT
EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS WAR.
THAT'S WHY WE DO EVERYTHING TO
FIX, TO DOCUMENT EVIDENCE.
BUT WE ARE HERE IN UKRAINE
ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ALL OF THIS.
>> THE INVESTIGATORS WORK IS
COMPLICATED BY THE FACT THAT
THE WAR IS STILL GOING ON.
THEY CAN'T REACH MANY
DEVASTATED AREAS LIKE THE
ENCIRCLED CITY OF MARIUPOL
WHERE UKRAINE'S PRESIDENT SAYS
TENS OF THOUSANDS HAVE BEEN
KILLED.
BUT, ARENA SAYS THAT NO MATTER
HOW LONG IT TAKES, SHE WILL
PRESS ON.
>> IT'S ACTUALLY EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT, OF COURSE, IF WE
WILL BE SUCCESSFUL AS A
PROSECUTOR.
I AM SURE THAT WE CAN STOP SUCH
AGGRESSIONS IN THE FUTURE.
>> FRED LANKIN, CNN, BUCHA,
UKRAINE.
>> JOINING ME NOW, NATALIA, AS
AN INDEPENDENT JOURNALIST IN
KYIV.
WE APPRECIATE YOU BEING WITH
US.
I KNEW AT A VERY LATE NIGHT, SO
THANK YOU FOR GETTING UP AND
MAKING THE TIME.
YOU'VE JUST RETURNED FROM SOME
AREAS OUTSIDE CHERNIHIV.
AND SOME PARTS HAVE BEEN LEFT
IN RUIN, AND IN SOME AREAS, THE
DESTRUCTION IS NOT THE SAME
LEVEL AS BUCHA.
WHY IS THAT?
WHY THESE AREAS --
I WOULDN'T SAY THEY'VE BEEN
SPARED, BUT THEY CERTAINLY
HAVEN'T SUFFER THE SAME FATE.
DO YOU KNOW WHY?
>> SO, YEAH, SURE.
JOURNEY OF IS THE NEW CAPITAL
OF THE NORTHERN REGION.
JUST SOME 70 KILOMETERS, 40
MILES FROM THE RUSSIAN, FROM
THE BELARUSIAN BORDER.
DAIRY OUTSIDE CHERNIHIV HAS
BEEN OCCUPIED BY THE RUSSIAN
TROOPS WITHIN THE FIRST, MAYBE
FIVE, SEVEN HOURS OF THE WAR.
SO THE MAJORITY OF THE TROOPS
MOVED NORTH AND THE DIRECTION
OF KYIV.
HOWEVER, THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO
OVERTAKE THE CITY WHERE 3000
PEOPLE LIVE.
THERE ARE QUITE ASTONISHING
DESTRUCTION, TO BE HONEST.
IT'S A BIGGER THAN WORRY YANKO,
EVEN IN SOME AREAS WHERE,
OUTSIDE OF THE TOWN WHERE
LITTLE HOUSES REMAIN.
BUT, THE DIFFERENCE IS THAT
THESE VILLAGES, BUCHA, MAYBE
THAT'S WHY THEY LOOK SO
SIGNIFICANT.
THERE WAS THE VENTRAL AREA WITH
HIGH BUILDINGS.
IN THERE, WE SPEAK ABOUT THE
VILLAGES.
SO MAYBE FOR SOME PEOPLE, IT
WON'T LOOK AS IMPRESSIVE.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, A LOT OF
HOUSES, A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
TAKEN.
BUT SOMETHING TO TELL MORE, THE
CITY WAS FOUR MONTHS UNDER
SIEGE.
THE CITY IS QUITE LARGE.
THEY STILL DON'T HAVE WATER,
BECAUSE THE WATER PUMPS HAVE
BEEN TARGETED.
THEY HAVEN'T HAD ELECTRICITY,
AND WE SPEAK ABOUT IT ON QUITE
A LARGE TOWN.
IT'S ABOUT TIME TO BE FIXED.
MOST ELECTRICITY AND WATER, AND
PEOPLE ARE COMING BACK TO LIFE
TO THE TOWN.
BUT WE ARE SPEAKING ABOUT
DOZENS, AND MAYBE EVEN MORE
VILLAGES WHICH, FOR ONE MONTH,
WE'RE LIVING WHERE RUSSIAN
TROOPS WERE LIVING.
SO, THERE WE SEE VARIOUS
DIFFERENT STORIES.
OF COURSE, THE SCALE COULD BE
DIFFERENT BECAUSE, FOR INSTANCE,
BUCHA 30,000 PEOPLE.
AND THE VILLAGE WOULD BE 1000
PEOPLE.
BUT FOR INSTANCE, I'VE BEEN TO
VILLAGE IT'S IN THE OUTSKIRTS
OF TWO NEW.
SO, THERE WAS THE CASE.
>> NATALIA, LET ME JUMP IN
THERE, FOR A MOMENT.
FLIPPING CLEAR YOUR THROAT.
I'LL JUST ASK YOU THIS
QUESTION.
I KNOW YOU'VE HAD A VERY HARD
LATE NIGHT SO WE APPRECIATE YOU
BEING WITH US.
BUT YOU MENTIONED THAT A LOT OF
RESIDENTS IN THESE AREAS HAD
ACTUALLY HAVE DISAPPEARED.
DO YOU KNOW WHERE THEY ARE?
ARE THE COUNTED FOR?
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT HEARING THOSE
SORT OF STORIES GOING FROM
THESE AREAS OUTSIDE OF TURN
I'VE.
>> I DO THINK THAT WE ARE NOT
YET HEARING THE STORIES.
THE JOURNALISTS WOULD GO TRAVEL
THERE.
IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ACCESS TO
THOSE AREAS BECAUSE THE CITIES
AND THE VILLAGES ARE BASED ON
THE SITUATION ON THE REVERSE.
AND MOST OF THE REGIONS WERE
BLOWN UP.
SO, THAT WAS THE PROBLEM.
THERE IS NO FUEL IN THIS AREA.
SO ANY TRIP THERE, IT'S A BIT
OF AN ADVENTURE THEY NEED TO
THINK OF WHAT IT SO LOT OF
PLACES WERE NOT YET VISITED BY
THE JOURNALISTS BUT SOMETHING
THAT I MANAGED TO DO, ABOUT SIX
VILLAGES, AND YES, EVERY
VILLAGE WE HEAR THE STORIES
ABOUT PEOPLE FOR INSTANCE, IS A
DETAINED?
THERE WERE PEOPLE WHO WERE SHOT
ON THE SCALE WOULD'VE BEEN
DIFFERENT.
PRIVILEGED THREE, FOUR, FIVE,
SEVEN PEOPLE WILL BE AN
IMPRESSIVE AMOUNT.
BUT IN ONE OF THEM, THE STORY
WHICH WE FIND QUITE OUTSTANDING
IN UKRAINE.
THE HUNDRED AND 70 PEOPLE, FOR
ONE MONTH, THEY WERE PUSHED AND
TAKEN BY THE RUSSIAN TROOPS TO
THE BASEMENT OF THE SCHOOL, AND
WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO GO OUT.
THEY SPENT THEIR TIME THERE
WHILE THE RUSSIAN TROOPS USED
THE SCHOOL AS THEIR MILITARY
BASE FULL OF EQUIPMENT.
SO THE STRATEGY WAS THAT THEY
WON'T BE ATTACKED BECAUSE THE
WHOLE VILLAGES ACTUALLY LIVING
UNDER THEM.
IT WAS QUITE HORRIFIC
CONDITION.
SOME ELDERLY COULDN'T REALLY
SURVIVE THAT SITUATION.
AND ALSO, PEOPLE ARE SAYING
THAT SOME OF THE SOLDIERS WERE
DELIBERATELY RULED.
SO IT'S A DIFFERENT DYNAMIC,
BECAUSE FOR ONE MONTH, THE
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS WERE LIVING IN
THE HOUSES OF THE PEOPLE, WITH
THE PEOPLE, IN THEIR BASEMENTS.
BECAUSE THEY TRIED TO STAY
EXACTLY WITH THE PEOPLE NOT TO
BE TARGETED.
THOUGH, THAT STILL THE STORY TO
BE TOLD, BECAUSE WE ARE
SPEAKING ABOUT MANY PLACES AND
JUST ADD, THE FIRST THREE
VILLAGES I VISITED JUST BY
OCCASION, I MET A MAN WHO WOULD
SAY, I LOST MY SON, MY SON'S
BEEN KILLED DOESN'T MEAN THAT
EVERYBODY IS LIKE THE BUT, FOR
JOURNALISTS, IF YOU HAVE THIS,
IT ALSO SHOWS QUITE A SPECIFIC
DYNAMIC.
>> NATALIA, WE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR REPORTING THANK
YOU FOR SHEDDING LIGHT ON